hey everybody I'm James Gunn I'm the
co-ceo of DC Studios so as many of you
know DC has been disconnected in film
and television for a long time and it's
one of you know our jobs mine and Peters
is to come in and make sure the DCU is
connected in film television gaming and
animation that the characters are
consistent played by the same actors and
it works within one story and if
something is outside of that like Matt
Reeves Batman or Todd Phillips Joker or
Teen Titans Go that it is clearly
labeled as DC else worlds outside of the
mainstream DCU continuity now Peter and
I have gotten pretty lucky in terms of
the four projects that are coming out
over the next year first we have Shazam
Fury of the Gods Shazam has always been
off kind of in his own part of the DCU
so he connects very well that moves
directly into the flash a fantastic
movie that I really love that Reese sets
the entire DC Universe then to move into
Blue Beetle a fantastic film about a kid
who's a marvelous part of the DCU and
then into Aquaman 2 which leads directly
into our next few projects which I'm
going to tell you about now so Peter and
I along with a group of very talented
writers have started to map out an eight
to ten year plan of what DC Studios will
be in film television and gaming this
first chapter is called Gods and
Monsters now this what I'm about to tell
you is a part of the first chapter it's
not the entire first chapter
first project is Creature Commandos
Creature Commandos is an animated series
I've written all the episodes something
we're going to do that's a little bit
different at DC is we're going to have
characters move into animation out of
Animation usually having the same actor
play their voice as who plays them in
live action the next project up is
Waller this is a story of Amanda Waller
who played by Viola Davis Viola Davis is
going to team up with members of Team
Peacemaker and this is a story that's
been created by Crystal Henry who did
Watchman and Jeremy Carver who created
the Doom Patrol it is a fantastic story
that's out of this world and I can't
wait for people to see it okay next up
is the big one the true beginning of the
DCU this is called Superman Legacy this
is being written by me I'm in the middle
of it I'm having a great time doing it
and Superman will be released into
theaters July 11 2025. okay the next
thing is a big Premiere HBO television
series series called lanterns this is a
story of a couple of Green Lanterns Jon
Stewart and Hal Jordan and we have a few
other lanterns peppered in there but
this is really a terrestrial based TV
show which is almost like True Detective
with a couple of Green Lanterns who are
space cops watching over Precinct Earth
in it they discover a terrifying mystery
that ties into our largest story of the
DCU next is a big movie called The
Authority The Authority is a passion
project of mine it's based on The
Marvelous wildstorm characters we are
now bringing into the DCU and will
interact with all of our primary DCU
characters The Authority are a group of
superheroes who think the world is
broken and they want to fix it by any
means necessary I think it's a very
different look at superheroes we're
doing a television series called
Paradise Lost Paradise Lost is a story
of Paradise Island usually known as
themescara which is the birthplace of
Wonder Woman it's almost like Game of
Thrones with Westeros but with all of
the inhabitants of Paradise Island the
introduction of the dcu's Batman is the
Brave and the Bold the Brave and the
Bold is the story of Batman and his
actual son Damien Wayne this is based on
Grant Morrison's great comic book run
Damien Wayne is my favorite Robin he's a
little assassin who Batman tries to get
in line and so this is the story of the
two of them and the beginning of sort of
the bat family in the DCU next up is a
TV series called Booster Gold Booster
Gold is one of comic's really popular
cult Heroes he is a fascinating guy he's
a loser from the future who uses future
technology to come back to present day
and become a superhero so that people
will love him it is basically the
superhero story of imposter syndrome on
an HBO Max series one of my favorite
comic book series from last year was Tom
King's run on Supergirl woman of
tomorrow and so we're going to turn that
into a big science fiction Epic film now
Superman is a guy who was sent to Earth
and raised by loving parents we're a
Supergirl in this story she is a
character who was raised on a chunk of
Krypton she watched everybody around her
perish in some terrible way so she's a
much more jaded character and that
brings me to Swamp Thing the last thing
we're going to talk about a very dark
Horror Story in the origins of the
monster who is Swamp Thing and although
it's totally outside of the rest of the
DCU it will still feed into the rest of
the stories anyway those are the stories
that I can tell you about right now I've
loved the DC characters since I was a
child they're incredibly important to me
I knew that this was a once in a
lifetime opportunity to do something
very different one of the things that's
very important for me in all of these
movies and TV series is that the
director's vision and the vision of the
writers and all of the creators is
unique and something special
storytelling is always king that's all
that matters to us and I want to be true
to those stories I want to be true to
you guys and really give you something
different than you've ever seen before
anyway thank you everybody I appreciate
you watching I hope this was exciting
for you because it's really exciting for
me and I can't wait to start to dive
into these stories with you guys on this
Grand Adventure thank you so much